بعد هذا الظهر مثلا الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب
بناء على
على ما خلص اليه
نتائج
المتعلقه بهيئه المحلفين ان هناك اربعه
جنائيه
والتي ترمي لاخفاء بعض الجرائم الاخرى هذه
هي طبيعه القضيه الخاصه
ثلاث
اربعه وثلاثون جنايه لتغطيه جرائم اخرى
وهذه تعد جرائم في ولايه نيويورك بصرف
النظر عن عن اي شخص انت تكون فنحن لن نقوم
بالتهاون مع اي جرائم ذاتها طابع خطير
والمدعى عليه قد قد قام على الدوامه
بتزوير مستندات تجاريه ودفع الاخرين الى
تزويرهم هذه المستندات حتى ان محاميهم
ماكل كوهن قيل بانه قد تلقى هذه الدفعات
لقاء اتعابه القانونيه وهذا بكل بساطه غير
صحيح وكان هناك ايضا تصريح زائف وغير
صحيحه الذي قد ورد شهرا تلو الاخر في
العام
2017 في مايو وجون ويوليو حتى نهايه العام
لمده تسعه اشهر على التوالي المدعى عليه
احتفظ بمستندات في منزله تحتوي على تلك
المعلومات وقد قال بانه قد دفع لمايكل
كوهن على الخدمات التي انجزها في عام 2017
وقد وقع شخصيا على شركات لمايكل كوهن طوال
الاشهر تسعه بالاجمالي توصلت هيئه
المحلفين ان هناك 34
قضيه بناء على تلك التصريحات الزائفه
لماذا قدم دونالد ترامب هذه التصريحات
الزائفه الادله تظهر بانه قد قام بذلك من
اجل تغطيه الجرائم المرتبطه بانتخابات عام
2016 دعنا ترامب
وهو
الذي كان يتراس
شركته قام بالتواصل مع بعض الشركات
الاعلاميه قد لجاوا كلهم الى ما يعرفوا
ان يتم
استخدامي اسلوب لمنع اي فرد من الكشف
العلني عن معلومات
وقد قام بدفع هذه الاموال من اجل عدم
الافصاح باي معلومات عن ترامب من اجل سداد
هذه الدعم سداد هذه الدفعات فقد تمت من
خلال الشركات وهميه وتلاتها تصريحات
زائفه وفقا لما اظهرته سجلات التجاريه ومن
احد هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين دفع لهم
من اجل شراء صمتها كانت هو اقل وقبل اقل
من اسبوعين من الانتخابات الرئيسيه
قدم 130 الف دولار الى محامي
هذه الدفعه قد تم اخفاؤها عن جمهور الذي
كان يصوت
وهذا
وهذا دفعه ليقول بان
دفعه لجعل السيد طهن من اجل سداد هذه
المبالغ اللي تغطيه عن الجرائم التي تم
ارتكابها في السنه السابقه
وكانت الخطه
التي قدمها تعتمد على تصريحات زائفه
وكانوا ينوون من خلال ذلك الى عدم اظهار
طبيعه
المبالغ التي قد يتم التي يجب الافصاح
عنها امام السلطات الضريبيه
هو الجرائم التي تم تقديمها من قبل هيئه
المحل نهايه المحلفين هي عباره عن جنح
وجرائم فهناك سجلات مزيفه في كل مكان
والتي تعد ذات طابع مهم في منهج التي تشكل
المركز المالي للعالم لذا فان
لذا فاننا نقوم بانفاذ القوانين الصارمه
في بشان هذه الكرامه
فانا مكتبي والفريق العام قام
بالوقوف على مئات من السجلات الزائفه التي
ترقى للجرائم
ولهذا فان
قمنا بالاطلاع ومحاكمه على كل من خالف
قوانين السريه المصرفيه وهؤلاء الذين كان
يسعون لتغطيه جرائم جنسيه وقد عملنا ايضا
على توجيه لهؤلاء الاشخاص الذين ارتكبوا
انتهاكات ضريبيه
وهذا
ياتي في صميم تلك القضيه والادعاءات حال
هذه القضيه مثل القضايا الاخرى
والتي تخص شخص يكذب باستمرار من اجل
التغطيه على مساله اخرى ويجب ان يكون
مسؤولا امام القانون وكما قام هذا المكتب
في اكثر من مره فنحن اليوم نقوم
بمؤازره مسؤوليتنا لضمان بان اي شخص لن
يكون فوق القانون بصرف النظر عن الاموال
او السلطه التي يمتلكها فهذا لن يغير من
المبادئ الامريكيه وانا مستعد لتلقي
الاسئله الان
هناك محاججه فالبعض يقول بان هذه المحاكمه
مدفوعه بطابعا سياسي
اكثر من عشرين عاما وتطرقت الى قضايا ذات
طبيعه معقده
وقمت باجراء تحقيق كامل
بشان هذه القضيه
فيما يتعلق
بتزوير
السجلات التجاريه التي يرمى منها
لاخفاء جريمه اخرى لكن لا نعلم ما هي
طبيعه تلك الجرائم الاخرى التي نفترضها
لقد لقد حددت لائحه الاتهامات هذه المساله
وقد ذكرت في كلمه التمهيديه جمله من
القوانين اولا قانون انتخابات الولايات
نيويورك الذي يجرم التعامر
بشان الترشح للرئاسه بطريقه غير قانونيه
وجمله من الوسائل غير القانونيه بما في
ذلك تقديم تصريحات زائفه
وكذلك اشرت الى قانون الانتخابات
الفيدرالي الذي لديه بعض الحدود القانونيه
[موسيقى]
لن اتطرق الى مساله التهم التي اثرناها
لان الادله هي التي تعد الاساس في اتخاذ
هذه القرارات
لن اتطرق بكافه التفاصيل الى ما حدث
ولكننا كنا قد اطلعنا على هذه القضيه
لمده عده اشهر
والتحقيق لا يتعلق فقط بالسلوك والاداره
التي تخص المدعي العامه وبعد فتره سوف
يكون لدينا الكثير من الادله والشهود وكما
ذكرت فقد قمت بمزاوله مهنه لعقدين من
الزمن ولا اقوم بطرح اذا قبل ان يتم
التحقيق بها بصوره كامله
هل لديكم ادله جديده بشان التهم الموجهه
كما ذكرت للتو
لقد توفر لمكتبنا الجمله من الادله
الاضافيه لكن لن اتطرق اليها الان
وقبل طرح سؤالك عن القوانين الفيدراليه
وتذكروا ان منحاه هي العاصمه التجاريه
للعالم
وينظروا ونقوم دائما بالنظر بالقضايا التي
تحمل في طياتها اي عمليات التزوير
التجاريه التهم
هناك تزوير حتى في سجلات تجاريه في ولايه
نيويورك
طبيعه اللغه التي تحدثت بها من قبل
المتعلقه بالتزوير تتطلبوا كما حددتها
تماما
سلوكا اجرامي قد تم اخفائه هو واحده من
الجرائم المزعومه هي
تتعلق بقانون الانتخابات
الفيدرالي
والتي تعود الى جمله من الاشياء من بينها
الرسائل النصيه وايميلاته وعدد من الشهود
كل هذه سوف
سوف سوف تصبح معروفه في قاعه المحكمه في
منهات
انني سعيد لانك اشرت الى هذا الموضوع لان
الامر لا يتعلق فقط بدفعه واحده بل اربعه
وثلاثين سجل تجاري واربعه وثلاثين تصريحا
مزيف واخفاء سلوك
وتصرفا اجرامي فيما يتعلق بسؤالك سابق
المؤامره من اجل تعزيز ترشح احد ما بطرق
غير قانونيه ونقوم بزعمها بما في ذلك
السلوك والتصرف بطريقه غير قانونيه فضلا
عن التصريحات غير
الصحيحه فيما يتعلق بالدفعات الضريبيه
للسلطات المعنيه بدران ليس فقط الدفعه 130
الف دولار شكرا جزيلا